here at Devil's in 2016 there's so much
excitement in the fourth Industrial
Revolution and a primary component of
that is an artificial intelligence the
fact that a eyes can read us and much of
that work was work pioneered by CMU
faculty and now the rest of the world is
coming along and saying what can we do
with this how can we use this to
increase safety how can we use this in
health treatment how can we use this in
making apps more user-friendly so it's
very exciting to see that this research
that's been going on for five years is
really a center stage big companies have
started to release a lot of the
technologies which previously were only
hidden inside the companies so now if
you want to do big machine learning or
big computer vision you can just use
that while you're inventing some whole
new application Carnegie Mellon has
actually got a position of
responsibility right now
AI can be really good or it can be in
some sense slightly frightening and I do
see our folks having disproportionate
importance in which way we actually go